guilty
[Applause]
huddled around their phones outside the
courthouse the news spread among the
crowd
derek chovan had been found guilty on
all three counts
there was elation but no illusions among
many of those gathered
we need to have justice this is the
first step we are not finished
this is the first step for our community
we are
satisfied with just this this is just
one step to it
i'm so glad that he got justice it's
been way too long
and i'm glad we're out here today
because if
i'm sorry i want to cry but i can't
there was disbelief but also belief
that the evidence of george floyd's
murder was incontrovertible
at the site of his death an area now
named george floyd square
emotions were particularly raw in other
cities
similar scenes here marchers in atlanta
in new york satisfaction at what the
black lives matter movement has achieved
despite the naysayers i'm happy for all
of the folks who are non-believers
for the last five years they came out
into the streets
for what was right and they got a
victory we should make no mistake
the protesters we've been hearing from
do not agree with the prosecution case
that we heard that
this was not the minneapolis police
department on trial
what we keep on hearing from them is it
is the minneapolis police department on
trial not only that it's the police
departments across the country
that were on trial and this verdict may
have brought relief
at justice finally served but there was
also the recognition
that the law would not bring george
floyd back
shia britancy al jazeera minneapolis